[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new marvel spider-man 3
video they just made a big announcement
is a huge easter egg for the plot of the
movie and a continuation of some
long-running spider-man Marvel movie
Easter eggs
Tom Hahn was also talking about their
original plans for spider-man venom
crossover so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a movie ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your biggest theory about
spider-man 3 on the video we'll just
break this down top 5 style starting
with number 5 if you missed it Marvel
recently announced that the working
title of spider-man 3 is officially
serenity now that'll bring some bells is
based on the Seinfeld episode called the
serenity now
in that episode George is advised to
scream serenity now every time he gets
too crazy was stressed to keep his blood
pressure down and throughout the episode
George just faces ever-increasing
circumstances that caused him to get
really pissed off and freaked out more
and more so he keeps yelling serenity
now louder and louder over and over
again this plays into the very
long-running tradition Marvel has of
using Seinfeld Easter eggs in the new
Tom Hollands spider-man movies and it
also informs a little of what the plot
is going to be so number 4 the
long-running tradition of Seinfeld
Easter eggs started with spider-man
homecoming when they named the movie
summer of George as the working title
after the title of the Seinfeld episode
the reason why they named spider-man
homecoming summer of George that time
wasn't so much because the plot of
spider-man homecoming was similar to the
plot of that episode that time it was
mostly because the director John Watson
the crew during the pre-production on
the movie spent a lot of time talking
about Seinfeld episodes while they were
in development so of course when it came
time to film spider-man far from home as
a way to continue that tradition of
Easter eggs they named the movie fall of
George when Spiderman far from home was
in development even though fall of
George isn't the title of an actual
Seinfeld episode it was just a way for
them to continue the joke into the next
spider-man movie it's kind of like their
tradition of putting home in the final
title of all the spider-man movies
spider-man Home Coming spider-man far
from home implying that the title of
spider-man 3 will eventually be
something with
home in the title the new working title
for spider-man three serenity now is
much closer of a reference to the actual
plot of the movie while still continuing
that Seinfeld tradition side note -
because we know that they're making
spider-man 4 with Marvel and Sony
together it also kind of implies that
they're gonna be using home in the title
of that as well so we're running out of
big ideas I'll talk about that in a
second how many titles can you come up
with with home in the title that
actually sound like good spider-man
movies number three though the Serenity
now title plot Easter Egg is all about
what's happening with spider-man after
the events of the spider-man far from
home post credit scene where J jonah
Jameson and Mysterio publicly out his
secret identity and frame him for
Mysterio's death making it open season
on spider-man for the entirety of
spider-man 3 obviously part of the
teaser is that they'll find some way to
clear his name and prove that Mysterio
was lying about him but that's only
after they spend most of the movie on
the run from new spider-man villains and
more potential sinister six villains as
part of the larger Marvel Sony moves
that they're making with the sinister
six movie that also kind of gets into
the spider-man Easter eggs that we saw
during the Morbius trailer in the
implied crossover spider-man references
during venom - even though we're still
waiting on the venom 2 trailer if they
put that much spider-man stuff in
Morbius referencing MCU stuff real safe
bet that there's even more that going on
during venom - number 2 WTF the
spider-man vs. sinister 6 connection
from the Morbius trailer in the Morbius
movie is part of the larger Marvel Sony
plans for crossing Tom Hollands
spider-man from the MCU
over with venom I say venom but it's
really anybody else that they want to
put in those movies because you have
carnage you have Morbius and any other
potential spin-off characters that they
develop Tom Holland was recently doing
interviews for another movie that he
just made so here's a clip of him
talking about their original big plans
the future for spider-man was still very
bright with Sony and we had a really
really wonderful idea of how we could
sort of transition into a Spider Man
without the MCU and Tom Ross been a
named Pascal were really confident that
they were gonna do justice and make a
film of the caliber that spider-man
requires but that said I'm really glad
to be back in the MCU and to have the
team back together because I kind of
feel like it's where he belongs now I'm
really grateful that Bob Iger and Tom
rossman allowed me to be a part of the
process of bringing him home
it was a pretty cool experience and also
the best bragging rights ever I save
spider-man yeah it was really drunk yeah
I saw Bob Iger recently a couple of days
ago in LA and I said to him I said when
you come to London I want to take you to
the pub to have a point and we can talk
about how spider-man it's gonna be it's
gonna continue to be an amazing
franchise for both Disney and Sony
remember when they made it seem like
Spiderman was out of the MCU last year
for a hot minute that all of a sudden
the CEOs got involved and fixed it they
signed a new sharing deal originally
Sony had the rights to use all the
sinister six characters that they wanted
to so putting all the vultures sinister
six
spider-man scenes in the Morbius movie
was part of them hedging their bets for
the future of Tom Hollands spider-man
early on before they signed the new
sharing deal with Marvel but then Marvel
and Sony came back together just as they
were getting ready to finish the Morbius
movie so they made just a few minor
changes to how those sinister six scenes
played out made them a little more
connected to the events of spider-man
movies in the MCU like spider-man
homecoming and now in the words of Amy
Pascal way back during spider-man
homecoming days it's now much more
adjacent to the MCU than it was before
so that's how they're sort of connecting
the Sony venom verse to the MCU will
sort of see all that stuff play out and
it'll make a lot more sense when you
actually sit down in the theater and
watch the Morbius movie the other good
news is that the venom 2 trailer is
going to be coming in the next couple
months expect the same type of
spider-man Easter eggs in the venom 2
trailer even though the majority of
venom 2 is gonna be dedicated to
establishing the carnage symbiote is the
new main threat of the venom verse the
sinister six stuff is kind of a separate
thing from carnage right now so just
consider them two separate ideas I don't
know if Sony has any plans to try and
shoehorn venom or carnage or both of
them into the spider-man sinister six
movie it even though Sony confirmed that
they're doing spider-man four eventually
and it'll be with Marvel said in the MCU
they didn't say if that would be a
regular solo movie or if it would be
their full-blown sinister six movie we
won't find out about that till after
spider-man 3 comes out so don't worry
about that too much right now
but number one WTF who are the villains
spider-man will be facing in spider-man
3 that will earn the serenity now
Easter Egg ray now Kraven is still the
lead rumored villain just because the
director John Watts spent all of the
spider-man far from home pressed or
referencing his love for the Kraven
character saying how much he wanted to
use him as the main villain of the
spider-man 3 it doesn't get any clearer
than that it's gonna be awesome like I'm
so I'm so excited I want to I don't want
to give anything away but I'm so excited
about it the only bigger teaser they
could drop would be to release an
official poster with Kraven on it called
spider-man 3
another deep cut Tobey Maguire's
spider-man Easter Egg there Joe
Manganiello really does want to play
Kraven in the new Tom Hollands
spider-man movies so we'll see if they
let him do that because that would bring
it around full circle
if you don't remember he played Flash
Thompson in the very first spider-man
Tobey Maguire film so as a comic book
reader one of my favorite favorite comic
book stories of all time that's so dark
and twisted and unique is Cravens last
hunt oh yeah
that's that one is it's it's maddening
it's insane and and what an amazing
ending and a great turn so I mean that's
that's one of those that I would be they
have to they're gonna have to make that
it's too good of a story now looks like
Ravens apparently gonna get a solo movie
but in the same vein that venom is where
it's not in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they still want a Marvel
Cinematic Universe Kraven well you have
to have him crossover at some point
because if you I mean Cravens last time
is too good a piece of material to bet
it's like you know it's like Wolverine
the Frank Miller Japanese Wolverine but
you know you cannot tell that story yes
is that a role you would go for if given
the opportunity for sure
well Craven yeah kidding me that would
be like a dream
[Applause]
plus you have the giant Craven Easter
egg in the Morbius movie that we saw
while they were filming and since Kraven
is an OG sinister six character Sony
also wants to do a whole solo movie with
them they haven't announced any official
casting for Kraven yet but if they do I
will totally make a video for it and
there's also the possibility they try to
include some more sinister six set up
during spider-man 3 and tease the
impending venom crossover movie somehow
I'm not actually expecting venom to show
up during spider-man 3 but I expect them
to explain a little of how spider-man is
going to wind up crossing over with
venom if that involves multiverse travel
a portal somehow or some other
explanation but post all your theories
in the comments how much sinister six
and venom teasers do you think that
they'll put in spider-man 3 and what do
you think the final title of the movie
is going to be spider-man homeless
spider-man home alone there are only so
many titles with home in them that you
can pick from there's a bunch of big
Marvel stuff coming up so I'll try to
get to all those videos as fast as
possible everyone click here for my new
Marvel spider-man 4 announcement
breakdown and click here for my brand
new venom 2 carnage first look video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome serenity now
[Music]